this cash today
yes always cash cash is king
all right black diamond black diamond
where were you from originally where did
you grow up
i grew up in sacramento but i was born
in richmond california
tell me about your family you had both
your parents when you were growing up oh
yeah i had
well i didn't know my daddy until i was
about maybe um
12. you know i met my daddy
on the whole struggle you know it was
another gentleman that ran up on me and
said you look like a pimp
i said i am a pimp i'm sitting at the
bus stop you understand because i'm just
starting out and everything you know i'm
about 12 years old
got two hoes and he said he looked like
a pimp i said i'm a pimp
no you look like a pimp you like this
pimp named fred lee
[Music]
i said okay that's my daddy name so he
wrote up on me introducing the quarter
this is back in 1978 wrote me and deuce
in a quarter and
uh he said man your name jeffrey
i'm like yeah
you see i'm your daddy i tell my daddy
name what's your name
he said my name fred lee you know i know
he was a pimp
you understand me and things like that
and he told me story about my mama
thing like that you know doesn't that
you know my mom was a hoe
all this you understand so i knew how i
got it and where i came from
you know and how was your relationship
with him after that
oh he was a beast he was a beast man
you know my daddy man was a beast man
you know it is a point where
you know he never he was like
co on me you know he had other kids and
things like that from different women's
and things like that
i couldn't find out you understand me he
was a player more than a pimp to me
you know because my mama told me a story
about him too you know
that she made him get a job made him
stop pipping and everything i'm like
okay
you know my [ __ ] [ __ ] make him
up or stop pimping
you understand me and then he tells over
my mama you know telling my mama yeah
your momma man your mother
you know mama made a [ __ ] let me
tell you about my mama though
after mate after may made a [ __ ]
trick by a house across three from his
wife
and his wife his wife had asked my mama
can he come home to
just babysit his his his kids
you understand me that's that's where i
come from mother you know i was born and
not sworn in
you know when the [ __ ] said they
born and i sworn i was really born in
this [ __ ]
you understand my uncles everything um
pepe comes through me i'm
i come out of when you know we started
out in fresno that's how i met virgil
you understand me one of the coldest
[ __ ] pimps i ever knew
on the side of mississippi i don't know
about the other side of mississippi
but on this side of mississippi he's the
coolest pimp i ever knew you know what
i'm saying
so you know i come up under this [ __ ]
man you know my mom was a house
bonafide house you know understanding
and when she stopped
hoeing she started babysitting for pimps
and hoes
my first [ __ ] come you understand me
i'm six years old
you understand me give me five hours in
bed can't and heard that it was a pimp
her mom was a hug
al perry you know out of sacramento you
know what i'm saying so i come
on i'm really raised under this [ __ ]
so when i get really irritated when the
[ __ ] say
man you know man pimps are born hoes you
know that pencil born
you understand i wasn't born with a
[ __ ] so i wasn't born with no pimping
you understand me one person pimp-borne
holds a mate you understand me i wasn't
born with no pimping
if i had come out of the womb with a
twin and pimp my twin then i would have
been born in some people
you know what i'm saying so you know
what i ain't come out the woman with no
hope
i have to learn this [ __ ] and i learned
this [ __ ] from [ __ ] like bird
joe
zach the mack hook the crook you
understand
stiffy danky you know what i'm saying
gang enrichment pimps you know what i'm
saying i can miss a million
[ __ ]
you know what i'm saying but i mean i i
get irritated
i get irritated with [ __ ] talk
about this pimping man
you understand me because pimping is
when you gotta hurt
i ain't got a hoe right now so i'm not
pimping but i'm a pimp
there's a difference i'm gonna be a pimp
to our diet
you understand me [ __ ] gonna sell sort
of metal base steal a bar
started watching destroy this gun strike
match kill the babysitter blood
whatever any [ __ ] i have you understand
i had a hoe tell me one time
you understand [ __ ] i i want to sell my
[ __ ] but sell what you got
[ __ ] i work seven jobs okay whatever
you do [ __ ]
but when you come in my door had the
money for show
you understand me that one makes a pimp
you understand me [ __ ] put the money in
my hand
i'm not no thief [ __ ] could put the
money down on the bed
i'm not gonna take that money off the
bed that's the best money until you put
it in my hand
so [ __ ] don't understand this
game it's not a game it's
a game we gain
i'm not gaming no [ __ ] i'm not gonna
play no [ __ ] i'm not a player
i'm not trying to play no [ __ ]
play a [ __ ] and make a [ __ ] i'm not
trying to turn nobody out
i'm trying to turn you on you know
[ __ ] you [ __ ] for free you go to the
club
and take a man home then you [ __ ]
this [ __ ] what is going on
everything like that [ __ ] i don't give
a [ __ ] but none of that
[ __ ] sell it
why you getting away for free you know
this this [ __ ] is it
is it it's illegal you understand me
who hefner playboy magazine
one of the biggest [ __ ] players
i ever knew
you understand me you know howdy flights
that big was a cold [ __ ] mata
you know what i'm saying when it comes
to
camping dog
who happened to
have to [ __ ] them whole the way we had
to do we had to pay them [ __ ] or
whatever a pimping a little bit [ __ ]
was a pimp yeah
how many how many girls would you have
at the at one time i had seven
seven i had seven hoes and what was your
style
you you've used force and intimidation
man you're a gentleman
i'm a gentleman you understand me every
pimp gonna be a gentleman i'm not a
gorilla
i'm not a little beast you know what i'm
saying i mean i'm not gonna force a
[ __ ] to do nothing
you understand i had a [ __ ] tell me i'm
gonna leave i told the business what you
need
you know taxi i'm gonna have to believe
i packed the best
clothes for the [ __ ] you understand
it's not it's by choice not
force the arrangement is they give you
all their money
and you give them what
when the [ __ ] give me some money you
understand i gotta have something
you understand me i don't i don't need
no sex
you understand last time i had sex man
you understand me i think i jacked up
1980 something you know
i'm just saying a [ __ ] when a [ __ ]
come in
to our comfort zone you understand when
you come in our comfort zone and
everything like that
you understand me it's more so we just
improving what you
what you are you understand you
understand me
look if she hungry
i'mma feed the [ __ ] if she needs shoes
i'ma put shoes on [ __ ] i'm a slave to
the [ __ ]
we explained to the hoe a pimp is really
a slave to the hoe
you understand the [ __ ] number will
give money we do everything for the
[ __ ]
daddy i'm hungry we gon feed the [ __ ]
daddy i'm gonna period
kotec whatever we get everything for the
best the [ __ ] don't do nothing she
sleep
and go work that's it
you know so when it when it comes to
when it comes to when it comes to
when it comes to mufflers say what you
do for the [ __ ]
i had a [ __ ] tell me one time [ __ ]
told me what a trick said
she said she said uh
daddy trick will say why you [ __ ] with a
pimp and everything like that you know
saying he'll do nothing for you
she said
what he do is nothing is better than
what you do
because everything she do if she crying
if she's sad
if she going through something you
understand we comfort the [ __ ]
we cater to the [ __ ] you understand me
that's why when back in the day you
understand me
you understand what they call uh you
understand me calling uh
uh um what's that word had was that
what's that [ __ ]
a gentleman a legion a jammer legion was
the man that when he got for the rich
man
the trick for the [ __ ] you understand
me or whatever it is just like me in
slavery when the [ __ ]
you brought the [ __ ] to the in-house
business in our house whatever it was
you understand me [ __ ] okay going in
there cook the biscuit whatever it is
bring this or whatever it is you
understand
so we're not taking advantage of the
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] is sharp you see [ __ ] are
real pimp
this guy they got red bottoms live right
now the [ __ ] out there with red bottom
song
you understand whatever pimp you
understand me going to look good too
he's going to be
elijah or whatever you understand [ __ ]
glad you're still tempted to look good
you understand but we don't take
advantage of that [ __ ]
that business was selling [ __ ] for free
she's going to a club or whatever it was
[ __ ] it for free
okay [ __ ] check it out come on [ __ ]
with me i'ma show you how to make this
[ __ ]
trick he's a trick trick em treat them
[ __ ] feed them we need them
you know what's been like trick or treat
smell my feet give me something good to
eat
you feel me so it's it is no difference
it's no difference you understand who a
[ __ ]
that go to a club and [ __ ] for free
and i see the [ __ ] i said damn you just
[ __ ] them up what'd you get
a drink that's all you got but i'm sure
i get you a thousand
but can you make it my bank can i hold
the money cause you know what to do with
the money
you understand me let me hold the money
and i guarantee you
so the girls you had were different
races
i'm a white horse pimp i'm a white house
pam
you understand me and that's not because
in fact
i don't love my black women or whatever
it is
but i'm not gonna pimp
my black women it's something against me
you understand me because my family was
like black panthers or whatever like
that
so i'm not i'm not gonna take them
to a level you understand me
and [ __ ] them up you feel me
and you you have sex with the girls or
no
i ain't never i got nobody by no
business
not no hoe i ain't no kids
[Music]
i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm i'm um i'm a
virgin
i'm really a virgin you know then i can
you understand
i get my nuts off and everything like
that it's like a square [ __ ]
and that's very rare
i'm not giving the whole my baby and
this [ __ ]
[ __ ] a pimp you understand me and
then i gotta go
tell him can i see my baby or whatever
you know what i'm saying he
feeding my baby bad or whatever like
that so i'm not going to
go that route so when i man
i understand how pimp stick they dick in
a [ __ ]
they don't to me they don't mean no
pimping to me
[ __ ] got baby by hoes i ain't
never seen multiple pimps guys people
hope when i was coming up
you understand me unless they didn't
marry their [ __ ]
you understand that that hoe that's been
there for 10 15 20 years or whatever
that's a down [ __ ] they talk about
bottom [ __ ]
about a [ __ ] gotta be a [ __ ] that
young thing with the penitentiary
everything went to youngster me a killer
[ __ ] with raising a hand
you talking to me i could cut your
throat or whatever
they make bottom [ __ ] in six months
i'll be about a mission that [ __ ] ain't
showing she's the bottom edge
the bottom is a [ __ ] i could stand on
that's what you call bottle [ __ ] to me
[ __ ] i can stand on you you my
[ __ ]
foundation i'm not gonna sink
[ __ ] with you that means a bottom
[ __ ]
what's most important to you in life god
god guys the most important thing to me
you know that's my that's my hang up
that's my hang up to the point where
that might make me take retirement
parties
because i want to you know understand
when i die
i want to go to heaven i believe in that
and so i know i can't go to help a
pepper
you know they didn't when their mother
said you understand me is people die
no not with me not with me
i'm not gonna put people before god you
understand me and so that makes me take
vacations on questioning my
you know lifestyle or whatever it is you
understand because in fact
i i want to go to heaven it's something
that i believe in
and so i knowing that pimping is a sin
sin is woman is a sin that's something
that
my flesh is doing you understand it's a
fleshly thing
you understand me you know but it's not
what my spirit should be doing and so
that
that that's the tug of war with me
just like was like when saul said
you understand it's a war is a war in my
spirit
you understand things i want to do i
don't do things i do do
i don't do you understand so it's that's
the war with me
if it wouldn't if it wouldn't it was no
such thing as god or if i die i just die
and i'll go to sleep and never wake up
again
and give a [ __ ] i would kill a gang of
[ __ ]
you understand me but i know i don't
want that
damage on me i gotta live some kind of
way
where god can say hey you know i got
some come come back
and that's the war against me i don't
know about other pimps or other people
or whoever but that's the war with me
i want to go to heaven you know and i
can't
pimp and die and go to heaven what
personality trait do you possess that
helps you do this
i'm a people person
i'm a people person i don't care what
love
walk of life you understand me
and i bless so many
you understand me pimp that see this
footage if you don't say
this diamond you know he didn't bless me
you know then i don't lie i tell the
truth
i'm the proof you know what i'm saying
me i guess i'm more than happy all these
homies out here
and my wife i got ten dollars in my
pocket muffler saying
man i need that 10 just give me a hit i
give it to him
because i can go home and i'm cool
i'm a people person i get along with all
walk of life
i don't judge no one you know and when
it comes to that point when you don't
judge no one
you understand me you win you understand
me
the bible say you understand blessed is
she forgiven
for he should inherit the earth so the
earth is my turf
you know you know i'm blessed
with no stress
what do you think the core of the pimp
and prostitute relationship is is
are the girls looking for a replacement
of their father
well when it comes to when you come to
a woman you say girl
i don't [ __ ] with girls yeah woman sorry
okay say woman
you understand when it comes to a woman
it could be
that she's i didn't say [ __ ] no you
said girl i know
keep girl i think at the footage i used
the wrong turn but it could have been
worse yeah but
girl the girl means somebody young yeah
yeah yeah you understand me so you can't
put that with pimping
you understand me because when it comes
to a girl i kill a [ __ ]
that sent a girl anything
under 18 needs to be dead
you understand i'm saying so don't use
that
but we not normal for pedophiles
you know what i'm saying so a mother
goes to jail for pedophilia and [ __ ]
with a young [ __ ]
yeah he needs to be killed when he go to
penitentiary
[ __ ] turn man you turn my daughter
out and she young
i killed you was she 18 did she grown
but you knew the relationship between a
woman and her
pimp yeah when it comes to that when it
comes to that it comes to that it comes
to that it comes to
can put his way i can see a young lady
walking up and i see her head now i can
read her spirit
you understand me she's down
she's moping about something and she's
looking for an
answer and she's looking for a clue so
when i walk through hey how you doing
darling
what you got a friend on your face
oh you know my daddy this is all my
boyfriend
okay well man you know that's that
happened there
you understand me and then you gotta
uplift her when you uplift her
you understand when you uplift that
individual
and you give her the answer you asked
all the questions in her head
she'll do anything for you because in
fact that's what she's been looking and
seeking and searching and
trying to find an answer and when you
can
answer the questions in her head
give a [ __ ] keys a nun
you the one look at charles master he
had been the killer for him
because he answered the questions and
they had
what they was going through look at jim
jones
you know i'm saying ask the questions in
their head
look at the preachers the pastors
whatever is going on
answer the questions if somebody asks
the question you hear
right now i can tell you how to make
this footage better
you'll give me on the pay line
that's how it is
the caller's pimp was was lucifer
[Music]
he made eve made adam a snitch
what did adam say when god came to the
garden and said where you at adam
he said i'm high why are you hiding i'm
naked
who told you with [ __ ] this [ __ ] you
gave me you understand me
you feel me this what you do
snake came through walking through the
garden
hey [ __ ] what's happening what's
happening right
back in that tree and everything
you know i surely don't know if you're
gonna die right now
you might die later you know that right
now
adam was tricked he was the first hulk
you understand me and a snake was the
current first pimp
lucifer if you want to go back to that's
why
pimping the horn being thrown the
[ __ ] bible you understand me
david sent the [ __ ] to the front
line for his wife whatever it is
i can tell you stories i'm wanting glory
you know man i'm deep with this [ __ ] man
i'm really invested in
pimping i'm like
[ __ ] go to college go to college
i know everything the depths of this
[ __ ]
[ __ ] ain't so they sold out a
little a lot of [ __ ] today
as you were saying earlier llama for the
day is pimping because
the dope games got slow
and so they thugs wearing jeans well
than that
but pimps are generous look at virgil
he's a gentleman zach to make a
gentleman
feel more slim with gentlemen
you understand against the browns
gentlemen kennywood and gentlemen
stiffy a gentleman hooked a quicker
gentleman
stippy agenda thank you a gentleman
talking about gentlemen gentlemen
you don't send me
[Music]
you know that's what i [ __ ] with
gentlemen's and we are never we
we we we never take it out of character
or whatever it is
you understand i mean pepe pew gentlemen
you know giants
you know
david fall gentlemen
you know honey dripper gentlemen
i want to miss so many [ __ ] man
i really do
and i want to keep all that footage i
just said
it's gentlemen's so i'm a gentleman
so i'm not going to make no [ __ ]
i don't need you let the warfare beat
you and let that suck keep greasing you
bro you [ __ ] with me investing is
pimping and we're gonna get rich
but i'm not gonna hide i'm gonna divide
it i'm gonna share it i'm gonna bear it
you understand me [ __ ] whatever you
need i guarantee you on that one for
another
never again are drugs are part of the
picture for you huh are drugs are part
of the picture for you
are you drugs do you use any drugs
do i take drugs oh no
no i did drugs yeah you don't get
twisted
i mean i don't know a pimple right never
did no drugs well i do have problems
with the drug exactly you understand me
i get something you understand me and
about when we don't pimp with drugs i'm
not gonna get a [ __ ] no drugs
you understand me i don't pimp night
vision [ __ ] ask me
uh can i get some drugs uh yeah i think
we
[ __ ] i'm not i'm not gonna [ __ ] with no
drug addict [ __ ]
not me you understand me
it is stealing from the johns part of
the game
no it's not a game and why you guys
there for the job
well i just i hear a lot of stories of
that i beat the [ __ ] up take something
for the job
yeah you know what i mean i mean you
know you ain't got to step on that john
[Music]
play him i mean the best player for
twenty thousand forty thousand he got
jury or whatever like that
he slipped but them still
you know it's a different from stealing
and playing
because he slept you understand me as
the [ __ ]
you understand me had a gang him up with
a jury
on the dresser in front of a house
he slept the [ __ ] would bring all that
to me
i need it but the [ __ ] ain't gonna go
look he's sleeping at the video look at
all his dresses and all that
[ __ ] she don't take money and keep on
leaving
but she could play him on it oh yeah
and she don't get it [ __ ] don't hold on
still nothing
i never seen a whole still [ __ ] a hoe
still is like taken
you know i'm saying when it comes to a
hulk because that
john left the jury on the dresser his
rolex and everything
on that [ __ ] gonna pick it up all right
man thank you so much for talking with
me
thank you thanks for coming down oh yeah
you